the lungs are part of the lower
respiratory
tract and contain a series of
subdividing tubes beginning with the
broni air passes through the broni into
smaller tubes called
bronchioles then into tiny elastic sacks
called Alvi where gas exchange
occurs pulmonary capillaries and Alvi
share a thin membrane through which gas
exchange
occurs oxygen diffuses from the Alvi
into the blood for transport to body
tissues and carbon dioxide a waste
product of cellular processes diffuses
from the blood into the Alvi to be
exhaled from the body
shifts in oxygen and carbon dioxide
partial pressures in the blood can
signal respiratory failure a condition
in which gas exchange is insufficient
due to disease involving the lungs or
other
organs in hypoxemic respiratory failure
too little oxygen diffuses into the
blood in hypercapnic respiratory failure
too much carbon dioxide remains in the
blood chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease known as
COPD and acute respiratory distress
syndrome known as
ards commonly result in respiratory
failure COPD includes two main
conditions chronic
bronchitis and
empyema chronic bronchitis involves
inflammation of the bronchial lining
thick mucus accumulation along the
bronchial lining and narrowing of the
Airways called Bronco
constriction which can result in blocked
or narrowed
Airways in empyema some Alvar walls are
destroyed leading to fewer larger
formless Sachs in addition some of the
bronchioles collapse impeding air flow
out of the
Alvi in contrast acute respiratory
distress syndrome involves injury to one
or both lungs caused by factors such as
trauma or blood infection called sepsis
inflammation leads to alv fluid
accumulation and and alv collapse
reducing the surface area available for
gas
exchange common treatments for
respiratory failure
include oxygen therapy via supplemental
oxygen or mechanical
ventilation other common treatments
include medications such as as
bronchodilators and steroids which
reduce air flow
resistance and antibiotics which kill
bacteria causing bronchitis and other
infections